le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
de nombreux jeunes voudraient lancer
leur petite entreprise mais souvent ils
font face aux difficultés du montage
financier et à la complexité des
dossiers en mai 2016 le conseil
départemental a lancé le tage tremplin
pour l'activité des jeunes
ce dispositif est une aide financière de
8000 euros maximum
il offre aussi un accompagnement
administratif et juridique
exemple avec stéphanie et thierry payet
qui ont ouvert leur restaurant de plats
à emporter
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur oui alors rapidement
c'est avec le sourire que stéphanie
payet accueille ses clients dans son
restaurant de plats à emporter
elle travaille avec son mari thierry
depuis le 28 octobre dernier le rock
express a ouvert ses portes à la plaine
des cafres projet sagem depuis longtemps
en fait quand on avait fini lisse aux
thoniers
on avait un projet tous les deux mais on
savait pas encore c'est quoi on aurait
aimé faire quelque chose ça ne s'arrête
pas là au fil des années
on a eu nos expériences bachar car on a
eu notre expérience lui en tant que
cuisinier moi en tant que ces pionniers
son carton celle un film et essai
courage et par la famille c'est ça fait
tout aussi que vous allez c'est bien
pour une vie de couple et moi qui n'y
est ce assez logique et elbeuf et
administratives malheureusement pour
elle pour lancer leur affaire ils ont
profité d'une aide financière
le taz le tremplin pour l'activité des
jeunes c'est une aide du département qui
permet de couvrir les frais liés à la
création d'entreprise ou au démarrage de
l'activité
elle est réservée aux jeunes de 20 à 30
ans au monde le projet au début on est
parti voir
la chambre des métiers à saint pierre
pour monter le dossier parce qu'on avait
on n'avait pas de financement on savait
pas par où commencer
je n'avais pas t'y voir on n'avait
aucune idée au début les poursuivants la
banque
mais nous à 10 cents dossiers valable
c'est pas possible de nous financer
parce qu'on avait besoin d'eux quand
même de 25000 euros pour brosser avec le
claj ni à une est de 8000 euros
cela a permis de faire un apport
supplémentaire même si je la paye tout
de suite demain dans le dossier puis
pour le dossier de financement
on a pu acheter du matériel a pu
commencer les travaux
et ensuite démarrer l'activité parents
de deux enfants stéphanie et thierry
jongle entre leur vie de famille et leur
restaurant leur volonté de travailler
ensemble a toujours été un moteur dans
leurs choix professionnels
cette aventure à deux n'aurait pas été
possible sans le tage cette aide pour
eux a été un levier pour engager un prêt
auprès des banques
les jeunes et les moins de 30 ans peut
aller voir les ventes en 10 ans pour la
journée et dès qu'on n'est pas tout seul
des gens nous aident à construire le
projet n'est pas un coup de tête c'est
pas on va par quatre du jour au
lendemain ça prenez moi si on a reçu et
a jugé que le premier aboutissement
dès l'ouverture le succès est au rendez
vous cette cuisine simple marie
spécialités chinoises et créole les
clients peuvent venir chercher leurs
barquettes tous les jours le midi et le
soir au royal a beaucoup de grains là
c'est bon on a eu beaucoup de monde mais
on s'attendait pas à ça du tout les
préparations c'était pour une
cinquantaine de repas ce jour là on a eu
quatre morts ou pas mais tu es super
heureux de savoir que ça allait marcher
avec 120 mille chômeurs dont 60% de
jeunes
la réunion connaît une situation
difficile du marché de l'emploi
cette situation dramatique représente
une priorité sous tendant toutes les
actions du département
chef de file de l'action sociale et de
l'insertion même si l'emploi relève
d'abord et surtout de la compétence de
l'état que nous voulons donner un vrai
coup de pouce à notre jeunesse pour
démarrer une première activité alors le
conseil départemental à travers le tage
voix apporter une bourse de 8000 euros à
ces jeunes qui vont avoir un projet et
ses 8000 euros faut savoir ne sera pas
remboursables et puis à travers cette
réussite c'est la fierté aussi de notre
jeunesse réunionnaise d'aller de l'avant
de réussir un projet qui lui tient à
coeur c'est sans regret que stéphanie et
thierry se sont lancés dans cette
aventure
finie la vie de salarié maintenant c'est
ensemble qu'ils doivent réussir à
travailler pour un patron et
du coup on essayait new malden notre
propre à fond et ça change
là au moins on sait où on va on a des
objectifs et caetera et on est
plus motivant radia avec de nombreux
retours très positifs sur leur cuisine
stéphanie et thierry espère fidéliser de
plus en plus de clients la qualité des
plats de thierry et l'accueil de
stéphanie sens pour eux des atouts très
importants
[Musique]
le taz tremplin pour l'activité des
jeunes a été créé en 2016 il s'adresse
aux jeunes âgés de 20 à 30 ans à la
recherche d'une insertion sociale et ou
professionnelle le taz est une aide
financière de 8000 euros maximum
permettant de couvrir les frais liés à
la création d'entreprise ou au démarrage
de l'activité
elle est attribuée après signature d'un
contrat d'accompagnement aux projets
d'entreprises cap pour plus
d'information vous pouvez composer le
numéro vert 0 800 1 801 000
[Musique]